Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Until the arrest of the former President Pinochet last October, Chile had achieved three remarkable successes, all of them in large measure due to former President Pinochet. First, it had seen the total defeat of communism at a time when that ideology was advancing throughout the hemisphere. As Eduardo Frei, the former Christian Democrat president of Chile put it, the military saved Chile. Secondly, Chile has seen the establishment of a thriving, free enterprise economy, which has transformed living standards and made Chile
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。要想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、新系列抢先收听，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。直到去年10月前总统皮诺切特被捕之前，智利曾取得过三项卓越的成就，而这在很大程度上都要归功于前总统皮诺切特。首先，在共产主义意识形态在整个西半球推进的时期，智利迎来了共产主义的彻底失败。正如智利前基督教民主党总统爱德华多·弗雷所说，是军方拯救了智利。其次，智利见证了一个蓬勃发展的自由企业经济体的建立，这改变了生活水平，并使智利
into a model for Latin America. Thirdly, Chile is also remarkable because President Pinochet established a constitution for a return to democracy, held a plebiscite to decide whether or not he should remain in power, lost the vote, though gaining 44% support, respected the result, and handed over power to a democratically elected successor. So that, Dominic, was Margaret Thatcher speaking in 1999, by which point she was Baroness Margaret Thatcher in the House of Lords. And I'm kind of vaguely remembering this. General Pinochet, he'd become a senator.
成为了拉丁美洲的典范。第三，智利也引人注目，因为皮诺切特总统制定了回归民主的宪法，举行了一场全民公投来决定他是否应该继续留任，他在投票中落败（尽管获得了44%的支持率），但他尊重了选举结果，并将权力移交给了民主选举产生的继任者。多米尼克，那是玛格丽特·撒切尔在1999年发表的讲话，当时她已经是上议院的玛格丽特·撒切尔男爵夫人了。我对此有点模模糊糊的印象。皮诺切特将军，他后来成了一名参议员。
He came to Britain, didn't he, on a visit to Mrs. Thatcher. He did. And there was a kind of extradition warrant put out for his arrest. By a Spanish judge on human rights violations charges. The Labour government of the day was put in a very difficult position, but they decided to honour the request for extradition. Pinochet was placed under house arrest, but eventually they found a loophole, which was his failing health,
他曾到英国访问过撒切尔夫人，对吧？是的。当时有一种针对他发出引渡令的说法。由一名西班牙法官以侵犯人权罪名发出的。当时的工党政府陷入了非常困难的境地，但他们决定履行引渡请求。皮诺切特被软禁了，但最终他们找到了一个漏洞，那就是他日渐衰退的健康状况，
because he was then advanced years. They claimed he was, it was said that he was suffering from dementia, I think, and he was free to return to Chile. And this was a very controversial story. Because my sense is that by and large, I mean, I can't imagine anyone who would be on Pinochet's side. That would be my gut instinct. My gut instinct would be, you know, the coup is a terrible thing. Yeah.
因为他当时已年事已高。他们声称他患有老年痴呆症，我想是这样的，于是他得以自由返回智利。这是一个非常具有争议的故事。因为我的直觉是，总的来说，我的意思是，我想象不出会有谁站在皮诺切特这一边。这就是我的直觉。我的直觉会是，你知道，政变是一件可怕的事情。是的。
But that's a reminder that there were certainly people in Britain, and I guess in America, because they were busy fostering the coup, for whom Allende absolutely was a menace, and her Rafa Pinochet. Yeah, you're absolutely right, Tom. You're absolutely right. In the last Chilean presidential election, which was in 2021, the winning candidate was a guy called Gabriel Boric, and he is an avowed fan of Allende, born long after Allende's demise. But he made a point on his inauguration day of going to the statue of Allende in Santiago and kind of bowing before it in kind of prayer and
但这提醒我们，英国肯定有一些人，我猜在美国也是如此，因为他们当时正忙于策动这场政变，对他们来说，阿连德绝对是个威胁，而皮诺切特则是救星。是的，你完全说对了，汤姆。你完全说对了。在2021年举行的上一届智利总统选举中，获胜的候选人是一个叫加夫列尔·博里奇的人，他是阿连德的公开崇拜者，生于阿连德倒台很久之后。但他在就职当天特意前往圣地亚哥的阿连德雕像前，以祈祷和沉思的姿态
contemplation, to say, I'm kind of in your shadow. But the man he beat, José Antonio Cast, who is actually leading in the polls today for the next Chilean presidential election, who's a kind of right-wing populist. He's the nephew of Pinochet's banking chief and campaigned for Pinochet in that very referendum that Mrs. Thatcher mentioned when he was a student. So in other words, there are still... This is not an open and shut case, as it were. There is a large proportion of Chilean opinion that would absolutely agree with everything Mrs. Thatcher
在雕像前鞠躬，仿佛在说，我正笼罩在你的阴影之下。但他击败的对手何塞·安东尼奥·卡斯特，实际上在下届智利总统大选的民调中领先，他是一个右翼民粹主义者。他是皮诺切特银行业主管的侄子，在还是学生时曾为撒切尔夫人提到的那场全民公投为皮诺切特拉过票。换句话说，仍然有……这不是一个盖棺定论的案子。智利有相当大一部分民意绝对会赞同撒切尔夫人的
said. And I think there are three points to make about that. One is, it's easy probably for us to forget that in the Cold War, a lot of people felt that you just had to pick a side. And that's what Mrs. Thatcher was saying there about communism and what Nixon and Kissinger would have said. You're with us or you're with them. And if you choose to go with them, well, God help you. Second thing is Mrs. Thatcher's economic program, what people now call neoliberalism. I don't really like that terminology, but people call it that. There are some, the attack on inflation, the very sort of abrasive, astringent medicine. There are definitely some similarities. And the third thing, and I think the most important thing for Mrs. Saturn from the British point of view, and there was no doubt about this.
所说的一切。我认为对此可以提出三点看法。第一，我们可能很容易忘记，在冷战期间，许多人觉得你别无选择，只能选边站队。这就是撒切尔夫人当时关于共产主义的言论，也是尼克松和基辛格会说的话。你要么跟我们在一起，要么跟他们在一起。如果你选择跟他们在一起，那上帝保佑你。第二点是撒切尔夫人的经济纲领，也就是现在人们所说的“新自由主义”。我其实不太喜欢这个术语，但人们就是这么叫的。有些人，对通货膨胀的打击，那种非常严厉、尖锐的药方。这其中绝对有一些相似之处。第三点，我认为对英国角度的撒切尔夫人来说最重要的一点，对此毫无疑问。
We talked about this in our Falklands War podcast. Pinochet did back Britain in the Falklands War. I mean, the thing is that to outsiders, the Argentines and the Chileans look kind of identical with their dark glasses and their enthusiasm for electrocuting poets, but they absolutely despised each other. I remember it, yeah. And the Chileans gave Britain loads of assistance in the Falklands War. So Baroness Thatcher, Dominic, in that same speech described Chile as this country's oldest and truest friend in Latin America. Right. Well, so there you go.
我们在马岛战争的播客中谈到过这一点。皮诺切特确实在马岛战争中支持了英国。我的意思是，对外人来说，阿根廷人和智利人看起来差不多，都戴着墨镜，并且热衷于电击诗人，但他们实际上互相极端鄙视。我还记得，是的。智利人在马岛战争中为英国提供了大量的协助。所以撒切尔男爵夫人，多米尼克，在同一次演讲中将智利描述为该国在拉丁美洲“最古老、最忠实的友人”。没错。好吧，就是这样。
So there you go, exactly. But Dominic, this is what sets this episode up, because I don't really know the truth about any of this. Right. I want to find out whether Allende was as much the goody and Pinochet the baddy as I've always kind of just vaguely assumed. Well, we ended last time in the spring of 1973. They've had congressional elections in Chile. Allende has been in for less than three years, but he has made this extraordinary beginning, redistributing land, nationalizing copper and banks and so on, pumping money into the economy and welfare spending and things. And yet at the same time, inflation has not really gone through the roof. I mean, it's gone through the stratosphere.
就是这样，完全正确。但是，多米尼克，这就是这一集内容的由头，因为我实际上并不了解这里面任何事情的真相。对。我想弄清楚，阿连德是不是真的像我一直以来隐约假设的那样是个十足的好人，而皮诺切特是个大坏蛋。好吧，我们上期节目结束时讲到了1973年春天。智利举行了国会选举。阿连德上台还不到三年，但他开了一个非同寻常的头，重新分配土地、将铜矿和银行国有化等等，向经济注入资金、增加福利开支等等。然而与此同时，通货膨胀并没有真正飙升。我的意思是，通胀已经冲上平流层了。
People's savings have been completely kind of debauched. People's living standards, if they're middle class, are falling rapidly. There's a sense of great hysteria among the middle classes. And I think it's actually, politics is always the clash of competing interest groups, isn't it? And you can completely see why, if you're living out in the countryside, very poor, Allende is your saviour. Allende is somebody who speaks for you. And as Ariel Dorfman said last time, makes you feel seen, gives you dignity. If you are a professional person, a lawyer or whatever, whose Uncle Jose's land has been redistributed, your savings have vanished because of inflation. You go into the shops, you can't, the shelves are empty, you're buying stuff on the black market.
人们的储蓄基本上化为乌有了。如果他们是中产阶级，生活水平正在急剧下降。中产阶级中弥漫着一种巨大的歇斯底里情绪。我认为实际上，政治历来都是相互冲突的利益集团之间的博弈，对吧？你可以完全理解为什么如果你生活在农村地区、非常贫困，阿连德就是你的救世主。阿连德是那个为你发声的人。正如阿里尔·多夫曼上期所说，他让你觉得自己被看见了，给予了你尊严。如果你是一个专业人士，比如律师或别的什么人，而你何塞叔叔的土地被重新分配了，你的储蓄因通货膨胀而消失了。你走进商店，却买不到东西，货架空空如野，你不得不去黑市买东西。
And those people are frightened that this is merely the beginning. I think that's the thing. We talked last time about Allende personally. Allende is clearly not, he's not Stalin. He's not even Fidel Castro. But a lot of these people think this is just the start of something. And actually, if it's not checked, what happens to Allende is neither here nor there, because somebody will replace him who will be much more left-wing more repressive all of this kind of thing so that's the anxiety on the right i guess which is important to understand and so it's a class-based as well oh it's absolutely class-based it's very class-based absolutely so we talked last time about how the results of those parliamentary elections in the spring of 1973 means that the Americans have basically given up all hope of stopping Allende by democratic means, sort of with a lot of money, before the end of his term.
而这些人害怕这仅仅只是开始。我认为这才是关键所在。我们上期谈到了阿连德本人。阿连德显然不是，他不是斯大林。他甚至不是菲德尔·卡斯特罗。但许多人认为这只是某种事情的开端。实际上，如果不加以遏制，阿连德个人的下场如何并不重要，因为会有人取代他，而接替他的人会更加左翼、更加高压、诸如此类。所以这就是右翼的焦虑所在，我想这也是理解这一点的关键，因此这也是基于阶级的吗？哦，这绝对是基于阶级的，这非常基于阶级，毫无疑问。所以我们上期谈到，1973年春天那些议会选举的结果意味着美国人基本上已经放弃了通过民主手段在阿连德任期结束前阻止他的所有希望，比如通过提供大量资金。
Dominic, just one last question on that. Do they have any qualms about that? Because the whole thing about America is that it's upholding democracy and the right of people to choose their own form of government. And that is one of the massive points of principle in the Cold War. They have no qualms about this. I wouldn't say they had any qualms whatsoever. I mean, I think that because they've been doing it for 20 years, they would say, I mean, I think if you're so. I think if you had, you know, not just Kissinger, because I think Kissinger is often too easy to make him. I think he's often made a scapegoat actually because of it because of he's a german jew
多米尼克，关于这一点我还有一个最后的问题。他们对此有什么顾虑吗？因为美国整套说辞的核心在于它维护民主以及人民选择自己政府形式的权利。这也是冷战中至关重要的原则之一。他们对此毫无顾虑。我不会说他们有任何顾虑。我的意思是，我认为既然他们已经这么做了20年，他们会说，我的意思是，如果你处于这种境地。我想如果你有，你知道的，不仅仅是基辛格，因为我觉得人们常常太容易把基辛格当作……我觉得人们往往把他当成了替罪羊，实际上是因为他是一个德国犹太人
i mean i know that's a that may seem a heretical thing to say to some people but i think it's very easy for people to pick on him rather than his predecessor dean rusk or any william rogers or any of the other you know the much more waspish kind of i suppose that they're all they kind of blur into one don don't they? They do. They do. And Kissinger called it the media in a way they didn't. I wouldn't say it's anti-Semitism in itself, but he's such a distinctive figure with his gravelly German voice.
我的意思是，我知道对某些人来说这可能听起来是个离经叛道的说法，但我认为人们很容易把矛头指向他，而不是他的前任迪安·鲁斯克或威廉·罗杰斯，或者其他任何那些（你知道的）更具盎格鲁-撒克逊新教白人色彩的人。我想他们都有点混为一谈了，对吧？确实如此。确实如此。而基辛格以一种他们没有的方式吸引了媒体的目光。我不会说这是反犹太主义本身，但他是一个如此与众不同的人物，有着沙哑的德国嗓音。
He is. He just stands out. Yes, he's become an avatar for American foreign policy more generally. But I think they would say, look, this is not a clean fight. The Soviet Union in Eastern Europe in the late 1940s twisted and abused democracy. If we have our hands clean, we will lose. We have to use their methods. That's exactly what they would say. So I don't think they have any qualms about interfering with democracy in that sense. But I do think that by 1973, they have already established links with the Chilean army. They have identified officers who, as we said last time, are sick of
确实如此。他总是那么显眼。是的，他已经成为了美国外交政策的某种化身。但我认为他们会说，听着，这不是一场干净的斗争。20世纪40年代末苏联在东欧扭曲并滥用了民主。如果我们保持双手动净，我们就会失败。我们必须使用他们的手段。这正是他们会说的话。因此，我认为他们在那种意义上干涉民主时没有任何顾虑。但我确实认为，到1973年时，他们已经与智利军队建立了联系。他们已经识别出了那些正如我们上期所说、厌倦了
their low salaries and things. They're quite a closed sort of caste, the Chilean army. Interestingly, because they're poorly paid, they can't kind of join in. They're too badly paid to kind of join in wider society very much. So they socialize just with themselves. They're in country clubs. Officers are often married to the daughters or sisters of other officers. So the Americans work very hard. It's a caste.
低薪等状况的军官。智利军队是一个相当封闭的阶层。有趣的是，由于他们薪酬微薄，他们无法真正融入。他们的薪水太低了，以至于无法过多地参与更广泛的社会生活。所以他们只在自己内部进行社交。他们出入乡村俱乐部。军官们通常娶其他军官的女儿或姐妹为妻。因此美国人付出了很大努力。这是一个阶层。
Yeah, to penetrate this caste and to basically bring them over to their way of thinking. Now, by the summer of 1973, quite a few people in the Chilean army think, okay, Allende just has to be stopped. He's gone too far. And there's a first attempt at a coup,
是的，为了渗透这个阶层，并基本上把他们争取到自己的思路上来。现在，到了1973年夏天，智利军队中的相当一部分人认为，好吧，必须阻止阿连德。他走得太远了。并爆发了第一次政变尝试，
which is called the Tanquetazo, which is at the end of June. Tanquetazo, because they use a lot of tanks. It's like an unimaginative name. This guy called Roberto Supa. And he leads these tanks into Santiago to try and topple the government. And it actually has nowhere near enough support. I think he has something like 16 vehicles.
被称为“坦克政变”（Tanquetazo），发生在6月底。“坦克政变”，因为他们使用了大量坦克。这是一个缺乏想象力的名字。一个叫罗伯托·苏帕的人。他率领这些坦克开进圣地亚哥，试图推翻政府。而它的支持率实际上远远不够。我想他大概只有16辆装甲车辆。
He has about 80 soldiers. They open fire actually on the presidential palace, the ministry of defense and so on, but it doesn't go anywhere. Allende speaks to the nation. He rallies support. The commander in chief of the army who rejoices in the name of Carlos Prats. Carlos Prats. Crazy name, crazy guy. He is the successor to General Schneider, who we talked about last time. And he similarly believes that the army should obey the constitution. So he persuades a lot of the mutineers to abandon the cause. And he gets his chief of staff, who is a man called Augusto Pinochet, to lead-
他有大约80名士兵。他们实际上向总统府、国防部等地点开火，但没有取得任何进展。阿连德向全国发表讲话。他凝聚支持。陆军总司令享有卡洛斯·普拉茨这个名字带来的声誉。卡洛斯·普拉茨。疯狂的名字，疯狂的人。他是我们上期讨论过的施耐德将军的继任者。他同样认为军队应该服从宪法。因此，他劝说许多哗变者放弃了这一事业。他让他的参谋长、一个名叫奥古斯托·皮诺切特的人来领导——
And that's how you pronounce it? Well, there are different pronunciations of Pinochet's name. So the classic thing is that everybody in Britain calls him General Pinochet. And then people who are sort of trying to be pedantic say, oh, no, actually, I think you'll find it's Pinochet. But having sort of dug into this a bit in the Bodleian Library, it turns out that the recordings of him saying his own name, Chileans often swallow the tea at the end of the word so actually what he actually says is Pinochet Pinochet yeah that's what we'll call him then but when we slip into because we're British so we'll obviously slip into calling him General Pinochet as people always do so listeners will just know J as in Che Guevara as in Che Guevara
这就是它的发音吗？嗯，皮诺切特的名字有不同的发音。所以经典的说法是，英国所有人都叫他“皮诺切特”（General Pinochet）。然后那些试图显得迂腐的人会说，哦，不，实际上，你会发现应该读作“皮诺切特”（Pinochet）。但在牛津大学博德利图书馆稍微深入研究了一番之后，事实证明，在他自己读自己名字的录音中，智利人通常会吞掉单词末尾的“t”音，所以他实际说的是“皮诺切-”（Pinochet）“皮诺切-”（Pinochet）。是的，那我们就这么叫他吧。但当我们不经意间——因为我们是英国人，所以我们显然会不自觉地像往常一样叫他“皮诺切特将军”（General Pinochet），所以听众们会知道，J 的发音就像切·格瓦拉（Che Guevara）里的 Che 一样。
yeah but in Britain people often say Che Guevara don As in Che Guevara, yeah. But in Britain, people often say Che Guevara, don't they? We just, we have our own distinct ways, don't we, in this island of ours. But we respect Chilean pronunciation, so it will be General Pinochet. Well, anyway, listen, he leads troops to help put down the mutiny. The mutiny fizzles out within hours. And Allende addresses this massive demonstration from La Moneda, from the presidential palace. And he gives this ringing speech at the end. He says, trust your government, go home, kiss your wives and your children in the name of Chile.
是的，但在英国人们通常说 Che Guevara，对……就像切·格瓦拉一样，是的。但在英国，人们通常说切·格瓦拉，对吧？我们只是，在这个属于我们的岛屿上有我们自己独特的发音方式，不是吗？但我们尊重智利的读音，所以将是“皮诺切特将军”（General Pinochet）。好吧，无论如何，听着，他率领军队协助平息了这场哗变。哗变在几小时内就烟消云散了。阿连德在拉莫内达宫（总统府）向这场规模庞大的示威活动发表了讲话。他在最后发表了振聋发聩的演讲。他说，相信你们的政府，回家去，为了智利去亲吻你们的妻子和孩子。
And everybody, hurrah, hurrah, the coup has been defeated. Isn't this great? But actually, that coup is just the warmup because there are lots of people in the Chilean military who look at this and they're like, well, you know what? Actually, it's a bit like the Prigogine thing in Russia. They got quite a long way without being stopped. There were only a few of them, and they came pretty close. So actually, we could learn the lessons from this, and next time, it'll be different. And the CIA, they are very optimistic. So they are actually, by the mid to late summer of 1973,
每个人都在欢呼，乌拉，乌拉，政变被打败了。这难道不是很棒吗？但实际上，那场政变只是一次热身，因为智利军方有很多人看到这一幕后会想，嗯，你知道吗？实际上，这有点像俄罗斯的普里戈任事件。他们挺了很长一段距离却没有被阻止。当时只有他们少数几个人，而且他们差一点就成功了。所以实际上，我们可以从中吸取教训，下次就会不一样了。而中央情报局非常乐观。因此，在1973年夏中期到晚期，
they are sending reports to Washington saying loads of the Chilean officers are talking about a coup. They're talking about dates. We reckon this could probably work. The one problem they have is this bloke, General Prats, because he is very loyal to the regime. Now, ideally, the CIA would love to have him kidnapped, but they tried that with the previous bloke in the last episode, and that was an absolute shambles. And had that been rumbled?
他们向华盛顿发送报告称，大量的智利军官都在谈论政变。他们甚至在讨论具体日期。我们估计这很可能会成功。他们面临的一个问题是这个叫普拉茨的将军，因为他非常忠于政权。现在，理想情况下，中情局很想绑架他，但他们在上一集的节目中对前任那家伙尝试过这个，结果一团糟。而且那件事败露了吗？
So did people know who it was that tried to kidnap him? So I think people suspect American interference, but the Americans don't want to do it again because it was a shambles the first time. It'd look very bad if it goes wrong. And it also might end up boosting support for Allende. People will rally to the constitution. But fate plays into their hands in a very bizarre way. In June 1973, General Prats has been driven in his official car through the sort of professional upper middle class areas of Santiago through an area called Las Condes. And at the time, a lot of the sort of, you know, the people on the right, when they see him, they'll kind of jeer him, shout insults at him because, you know, they blame him for
所以人们知道是谁试图绑架他的吗？所以我想人们怀疑有美国人干涉，但美国人不想再做一次，因为第一次简直是一团糟。如果出了差错，看起来会很糟糕。而且它还可能最终增强对阿连德的支持。人们会团结在宪法周围。但命运却以一种非常诡异的方式帮了他们一把。1973年6月，普拉茨将军正乘着他的公车穿过圣地亚哥专业的中上阶层社区，穿过一个叫拉斯孔德斯（Las Condes）的地区。当时，许多右翼人士一看到他，就会对他发出嘘声、大声辱骂，因为（你知道的）他们指责他
bolstering Allende. And he gets to the crossroads and this little Renault car pulls up next to him. And two people start making obscene gestures at him, shouting abuse and stuff. General Pratchett, he's a military man, Tom. He reacts as a military man perhaps should. He gets his gun and starts shooting at the car. That's how you think generals should respond to being insulted. Exactly.
在巩固阿连德的地位。当他到达十字路口时，一辆雷诺小车停在他旁边。车上的两个人开始对他做猥琐的手势、大声辱骂等等。普拉茨将军，他是个军人，汤姆。他做出了一个军人或许应该做出的反应。他掏出枪开始朝车子射击。这就是你认为将军面对侮辱应该做出的反应。没错。
He starts shooting. No nonsense. Well, he starts shooting at the car the cars both stop and the drivers get out general pratt's realizes to his horror that the driver of the other car that the crop haired driver of the other car who he thought was a man is actually a housewife called alejandrina cox and goodness so he'd misgendered her he'd misgendered her. He'd misgendered her. She starts shouting at him, you've been firing bullets into my car. Lots of passers-by gathering, they all take her side. There's a terrible scene of pushing and shoving and stuff. He actually ends up being rescued by a taxi driver. So this is a very embarrassing and shambolic incident. The Prats and Mrs. Cox
他开始开枪。毫不含糊。好吧，他开始朝着车子开枪，两辆车都停了下来，司机们走了出来。普拉茨将军惊恐地发现，另一辆车的司机——那个他以为是个男人的短发司机——实际上是一个名叫亚历詹德里娜·考克斯（Alejandrina Cox）的家庭主妇。天哪，所以他把她的性别搞错了。他搞错了她的性别。他搞错了她的性别。她开始冲他大喊，你一直在往我的车里开枪。许多路人聚拢过来，全都站在她这一边。现场出现了可怕的推搡和争执。他实际上最后是被一个出租车司机给救了出来的。所以这是一起非常尴尬且混乱的事件。普拉茨和考克斯太太
actually end up making public apologies to each other. They agree to kind of bury the hatchet, but this really damages his reputation. And the wives of his officers start to have demonstrations against him outside his house. And we can be absolutely sure this isn't some American thing. Well, I don't know. I mean, who knows? I suppose we can't, can we? We can't. I mean, no one, the Americans could not have known that he would start shooting the car.
最终实际上公开向彼此道歉了。他们同意冰释前嫌，但这确实严重损害了他的声誉。他手下军官的妻子们开始在他的住宅外举行示威游行。我们能绝对确定这不是美国人的阴谋吗？嗯，我不知道。我的意思是，谁知道呢？我想我们不能，对吧？我们不能。我的意思是，没有人，美国人不可能知道他会朝车子开枪。
They couldn't have put him up to that. Alejandrina Cox is clearly one of these people who is, you know, on the right, middle class, all of this sort of, you know, very anti-IAN day. But I don't think she's necessarily a CIA asset. Maybe the listeners, some of our listeners will know, and I would love to be corrected if I'm wrong. Anyway, Pratt eventually resigns. By the way, the key newspaper, Tom, in drumming up antipathy to him is, of course, El Mercurio, this newspaper funded by ITT and by the CIA. So the person who succeeds Prats on the 22nd of August, 1973 is his chief of staff, a man who's not been in this story at all up to this point, except for that little outing at the mutiny. And that is General Augusto José Ramón Pinochet Ujate. So this is Mrs. Thatcher's poster boy.
他们不可能唆使他做出那种事。亚历詹德里娜·考克斯显然是那种右翼、中产阶级、诸如此类、非常反阿连德的人。但我认为她不一定就是中情局的特工。也许听众们，我们的一些听众会知道，如果我错了，我很乐意被纠正。无论如何，普拉茨最终辞职了。顺便说一句，汤姆，煽动对他的敌意的关键报纸当然是《信使报》（El Mercurio），这家报纸是由国际电话电报公司（ITT）和中情局资助的。因此，在1973年8月22日接替普拉茨的人是他的参谋长，一个在此之前的故事中完全没有出现过的人——除了在处理那次哗变时露过一点小面。这个人就是奥古斯托·何塞·拉蒙·皮诺切特·乌加特将军（General Augusto José Ramón Pinochet Ugarte）。所以这就是撒切尔夫人的海报男孩。
We haven't talked about him at all because he's not been an interesting character. This is the extraordinary thing, actually. He is the son. He's the son of a customs official, Tom, like Adolf Hitler. Oh, well, that tells you all you need to know. If you are listening to this episode
我们之前完全没有谈论过他，因为他一直都不是一个有趣的角色。实际上，这是一件非同寻常的事。他是儿子。他是一个海关官员的儿子，汤姆，就像阿道夫·希特勒一样。哦，好吧，这说明了你需要知道的一切。如果你正在收听这一集的
of The Rest is History and you are a customs official, do better with your son. Yeah, exactly. Actually, his father wanted Pinochet to be a doctor like Allende, but he wasn't. He joined the army, which is a great way of sort of seeing a self-improvement in Chile, in Latin America generally. Also like Allende, he's a very keen Freemason. I wonder if they'd met in the lodge. I don't know. Well, obviously, they Latin America generally. Also like Allende, he's a very keen Freemason. I wonder if they'd met in the lodge. I don't know. Well, they'd obviously, they've met loads. They've met loads because Allende
《历史的余烬》，而你恰好是一名海关官员，请把你的儿子教育得更好一点。对，没错。实际上，他的父亲希望皮诺切特像阿连德一样成为一名医生，但他没有。他参军了，这在智利以及整个拉丁美洲是实现自我提升的一个绝佳途径。和阿连德一样，他也是一个非常热心的共济会会员。我不知道他们是否在会所里见过面。我不知道。好吧，显然，拉丁美洲通常也是如此。和阿连德一样，他也是一个非常热心的共济会会员。我不知道他们是否在会所里见过面。我不知道。好吧，显然，他们见过很多次了。他们见过很多次面，因为阿连德
thinks Pinochet is a fine fellow. He thinks he's very loyal, very reliable. He's a kind of dull dog, isn't he? He's a very dull dog. He'd been the commander of the garrison in Santiago. Then he was the commander of the whole Santiago province. When there were protests against Allende, Pinochet would command the troops. One of Allende's men said of Pinochet, he was the guy we would call if we needed a jeep. So he's just, as you say, they think of him as just a boring, loyal, a nobody. And actually the CIA and who and the american state department and all these people who are compiling reports on all the chilean officers they think exactly the same so this is a defense intelligence agency report quiet mild-mannered very business-like very honest
认为皮诺切特是个好小伙。他认为皮诺切特非常忠诚、非常可靠。他是个有点乏味的人，对吧？他是个极其乏味的人。他曾担任圣地亚哥卫戍部队的司令。后来他担任了整个圣地亚哥省的司令。当发生抗议阿连德的示威时，皮诺切特就会指挥军队。阿连德的手下曾这样评价皮诺切特：“他是我们如果需要一辆吉普车时就会打电话的人。”所以正如你所说，他们认为他只是个无聊、忠诚、无名小卒。实际上，中情局、美国国务院以及所有那些一直在汇编所有智利军官报告的人，看法也完全一致——这是一份国防情报局的报告：性格安静、温和、非常务实、非常诚实、
hard-working dedicated a devoted tolerant husband and father, lives very modestly, drinks scotch and pisco sours, smokes cigarettes, likes parties. And this is the CIA. Mild, friendly, narrow-gauge military man who is totally immersed in his new field of security, public order, and political events, and who clearly enjoys the feeling of being important. But all the reports say of him, he will not lead a coup. He is not the man. he is not the figurehead he's too dull he's like a staff officer he's like a number two or a number three
工作努力、敬业、是一个宽容体贴的丈夫和父亲、生活非常简朴、喝苏格兰威士忌和皮斯科酸酒（Pisco Sour）、抽香烟、喜欢聚会。而这是中情局的看法：性格温和、友好、眼光狭隘的军人，完全沉浸于安全、公共秩序和政治事件的新领域中，并且显然很享受那种受重视的感觉。但关于他的所有报告都指出：他不会领导政变。他不是那块料。他不是领袖人物，他太无聊了。他就像一个参谋军官，就像老二或老三一样。
and they would say if the CIA reckon if there is a coup he will probably go along with it because he was a you know he's part of that Prussian kind of ethos of the Chilean army but you know he's not a man for thinking outside the box. Not at all. He's utterly, utterly conventional and boring. The only interesting thing I discovered really about Pinochet is that, do you know who's a huge bibliophile?
他们会说，如果中情局估计发生政变，他可能会随波逐流，因为他（你知道的）带有智利军队那种普鲁士式的精神气质，但（你知道的）他不是那种能够打破常规思考的人。一点也不。他完全、彻底地因循守旧且无聊透顶。关于皮诺切特，我真正发现的唯一有趣的事情是，你知道谁是个狂热的藏书爱好者吗？
So he had a private library of 55,000 books. He would collect old books. When he became president, he would send his military attaches around the world to buy antiquarian books. But a very damning sign, Tom. As with so many middle-aged men, his library contains no fiction and absolutely no poetry. Oh, so this is bad news for all the poets who are being funded by the Allende
所以他拥有一个藏书达55,000册的私人图书馆。他会收集古籍。当他成为总统后，他会派他的军事随员世界各地去购买古董书。但这却是一个非常致命的信号，汤姆。和许多中年男人一样，他的图书馆里没有任何小说，也绝对没有任何诗歌。哦，所以这对所有正受到阿连德政府资助的诗人们来说是个坏消息。
government. Very, very bad news. Now, just as we move towards the break, August 1973, the climate is definitely getting worse. There is yet another trucker strike. There is, as we discussed last time, this rumbling constitutional row between the Supreme Court and Congress on the one hand and the Allende government on the other. The Americans have spent a lot of money basically pushing their friends in the Chilean Congress to be tougher on Allende. The Congress actually passes a resolution
非常非常坏的消息。现在，随着我们进入中场休息，1973年8月，局势无疑正在恶化。又发生了一场卡车司机罢工。正如我们上期所讨论的，一方面是最高法院和国会之间，另一方面是阿连德政府之间，爆发了激烈的宪法争端。美国人花了大笔资金，基本上是在敦促他们在智利国会的朋友对阿连德采取更强硬的态度。国会实际上通过了一项决议
to say that Allende is breaching the constitution, that he's using the power of decree too much, that he is undermining Chilean democracy. And Allende says, well, that is rubbish. It's you who is undermining democracy. It's actually that classic thing that you often get when you've got a kind of divided government between the executive and the legislature, where they're kind of tearing strips off each
宣称阿连德违反了宪法，他过多地使用了行政令权力，他正在破坏智利的民主。而阿连德则说，这纯属胡说八道。正是你们在破坏民主。实际上，这是一种经典的现象，当行政部门和立法部门之间存在某种分裂的政府时，双方往往会互相撕咬。
other. And there's a definite sense of rising tension. And actually, within Allende's regime, there is talk of trying to resolve this by having a massive referendum. And there are some people who say, actually, he was planning to give a speech on the 11th of September saying, look, this has gone on too long. Let's have a huge referendum. Are you with me or are you with the Christian Democrats in Congress? Which side are you on? I don't know how true that is. Of course, we'll never know. What we do know is that a week before the 11th of September,
局势中明显弥漫着一种日益紧张的气氛。事实上，在阿连德政权内部，也有人讨论试图通过举行一次大规模全民公投来解决这个问题。有些人说，实际上，他正计划在9月11日发表一篇演讲，内容是：“听着，这已经持续太久了。让我们举行一次盛大的全民公投吧。你们是支持我，还是支持国会中的基督教民主党人？你们究竟站在哪一边？”我不知道这有多大真实性。当然，我们永远不会知道。我们所知道的是，在9月11日的前一周，
there are massive demonstrations in Santiago by his supporters to say, we're with you, you won't be toppled, all of this stuff. They're chanting, Allende, Allende, el pueblo te defiende. Allende, Allende, the people will defend you. We're standing with you kind of thing. Ariel Dorfman, the playwright in his article about this in the New Review of Books he says, he was working at the time as a kind of cultural hanger on with the Allende regime, cultural advisor. And he says that in the presidential palace, people were saying, the army are possibly planning something, something could happen, but they don't really think it will come to anything because they know that there is this long tradition of non-intervention in politics. They're hopeful that people like Pinochet will stick to that. Actually, Allende's chief of staff,
圣地亚哥爆发了由其支持者发起的大规模示威活动，他们高喊“我们支持你，你不会被推翻”之类的话。他们高呼：“阿连德，阿连德，人民在捍卫你！”（Allende, Allende, el pueblo te defiende.）意思是“阿连德，阿连德，人民会捍卫你。我们与你站在一起”之类的话。剧作家阿里尔·多夫曼（Ariel Dorfman）在《纽约书评》上的一篇文章中谈到此事时说，他当时作为阿连德政权的某种文化附庸、文化顾问在工作。他说，在总统府里，人们都在议论：军队可能在密谋什么，可能会发生点什么，但他们并不真的认为这会酿成什么大祸，因为他们知道这里有着不干预政治的悠久传统。他们抱有希望，认为像皮诺切特这样的人会坚持这一点。事实上，阿连德的参谋长
Fernando Flores, tells Ariel Dorfman, he says, this guy Pinochet, I have him, I have him in this pocket, nicely tied up. He's our man. We can absolutely rely on him. And in a staggering irony, on Sunday, the 9th of September, Pinochet and one of his other officers, they meet Allende and have a discussion of what they would do if there was a coup. And Allende says to Pinochet, can you draw up basically a plan, what you would tell me what you would do? And Pinochet says, I will do, and I'll let you have it today or tomorrow.
费尔南多·弗洛雷斯（Fernando Flores）对阿里尔·多夫曼说：“这个叫皮诺切特的家伙，我把他拿捏得死死的，我把他揣在这个口袋里，绑得好好的。他是我们的人。我们绝对可以信赖他。”而在一个令人震惊的讽刺中，在9月9日星期日，皮诺切特和他的另一位军官会见了阿连德，并讨论了如果发生政变他们该怎么做。阿连德对皮诺切特说：“你能基本上起草一个计划，告诉我你会怎么做吗？”皮诺切特说：“我会的，我今天或明天就会交给你。”
And little does Allende know what is coming. Goodness. But you, dear listeners, you do know what is coming. Goodness. But you dear listeners, you do know what's coming. You know that after the break, we will be embarking on Dominic's brilliant account of the coup that overthrows Allende and brings General Pinochet to power. So we'll see you in a few minutes.
阿连德根本不知道接下来会发生什么。天哪。但是，亲爱的听众们，你们确实知道接下来会发生什么。天哪。但亲爱的听众们，你们确实知道接下来会发生什么。你们知道，在中场休息后，我们将开始聆听多米尼克对那场推翻阿连德并把皮诺切特将军推上权力宝座的政变的精彩叙述。那我们几分钟后见。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A
我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment），这是你们每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝秀场八卦以及问答环节的地方
we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets
我们带大家一窥娱乐界的幕后，并告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了我们的会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目以及现场门票的抢先购买权
head to therestisentertainment.com that's therestisentertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com hello welcome back to the rest is history now um just before the break i revealed what is going to happen in this passage i said that the end is going to be toppled pinochet is going to come to power and they told me off for having given away the climax of this narrative. But I think we've already given it away. And the thing is, Dominic, everyone knows this, don't they? Yes.
请前往 therestisentertainment.com，网址是 therestisentertainment.com，即 therestisentertainment.com。哈喽，欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。现在，嗯，就在中场休息前，我透露了这段内容里将要发生的事。我说过阿连德将被推翻，皮诺切特将掌权，然后他们就因为我剧透了这段叙事的最高潮而批评了我。但我认为我们已经剧透过了。而且问题是，多米尼克，每个人都知道这一点，对吧？是的。
I mean, this is, even if you haven't, I really know very little about the details, but it is in a way the kind of the archetype of a Latin American tragedy. It is. It absolutely is. I'm intrigued to find out whether it deserves that reputation and what it's done to get that reputation. Well, two things that people get wrong about it, though. First of all, they think of it as General Pinochet's coup. He did not plan it. There would be meetings from the beginning of September onwards among the Chilean, probably late August even, among the Chilean military, the Navy in particular, I think, and the Air Force and so on.
我的意思是，即使你没有——我对细节其实知之少，但这在某种程度上可以说是拉丁美洲悲剧的原型。确实如此。它绝对是。我很想知道它是否配得上这种声誉，以及它究竟做了什么才获得了这种声誉。不过，人们对它有两个地方弄错了。首先，他们认为这是皮诺切特将军的政变。他并没有策划这场政变。从9月初开始，智利军方内部——可能甚至从8月下旬开始——智利军方内部，特别是海军，我认为还有空军等等，一直在举行会议。
There are groups of them. Pinochet is only invited to these meetings or only becomes a real participant in them at quite a late stage. He goes along with it and nobody at that point thinks of him as the leader. Not at all. The second thing is that everybody thinks is that they think this is a coup planned, masterminded, orchestrated from Washington. Again, that is actually not really right. The CIA do not appear to have planned the coup. They knew it was being planned. They were delighted that it was being planned. And they, of course, lots of listeners will say they have created the climate or they have helped to create the climate. You see, I did not know that. I'd
他们有不同的派别。皮诺切特只是在很晚的阶段才被邀请参加这些会议，或者才真正成为其中的参与者。他随波逐流，当时没有人把他视为领导人。一点也不。第二点是，每个人都以为这是一场由华盛顿策划、主导、一手操办的政变。同样，这其实并不完全正确。中情局似乎并没有策划这场政变。他们知道政变正在策划中。他们对政变正在策划感到欣喜若狂。而且他们，当然了，很多听众会说他们制造了这种氛围，或者他们协助制造了这种氛围。你看，我当时并不知道这一点。我一直以为美国人是这场政变的赞助者。
always assumed that the Americans had sponsored it. Well, they have kind of sponsored it, but it's not their thing. They're not working hand in glove. Not probably as hand in glove as we think, or rather, I think the tendency, certainly in Britain and probably in many of the countries where we have Reston's History listeners, the tendency is to see the Americans as the puppet masters and the Chileans as the marionettes. Don't you think, Tom? I mean, then we do this with all, so much of the Cold War. And actually the marionettes have a life of their own, an agency of their own. And even if the Americans had never existed, I mean, it's hard to imagine this scenario in which the Americans don't exist, but
嗯，他们算是赞助者，但这并不是他们的主意。他们并不是紧密配合。可能不像我们想象的那样紧密配合，或者更确切地说，我认为这种倾向——肯定是在英国，也可能在我们拥有《历史的余烬》听众的许多国家——倾向于把美国人视为木偶师，把智利人视为提线木偶。你不觉得吗，汤姆？我的意思是，我们在冷战的很多事情上都是这么做的。而实际上，木偶有它们自己的生命，有它们自己的自主权。即使美国人从未存在过——我的意思是，很难想象一个没有美国人的场景——
there would have been people in Chile who would have wanted a coup and would probably have tried. Right. And so the key thing you say is that the role of Pinochet in this becomes all the more intriguing that the Americans have dismissed him as a non-entity and he is not involved in the drawing up of the coup. So Dominic, tell us, what happens? How does he end up becoming the figurehead? Well, there are different versions. Some people say that a couple of days beforehand, people say to him, we're going to do the coup and you have to get involved withhead. Well, there were different versions. Some people say that a couple of days beforehand, people say to him, we're going to do the coup and you have to get involved with it.
智利也会有人想要发动政变，并且很可能会去尝试。没错。因此，你所说的关键点在于，皮诺切特在其中的角色变得越发引人入胜：美国人把他当作无名小卒而不予理睬，而他也没有参与政变的起草。那么，多米尼克，告诉我们，发生了什么？他是如何最终成为领袖人物的？嗯，有不同的版本。有些人说，在几天前，有人对他说：“我们要发动政变，你必须参与其中。”
Otherwise, we'll have to get rid of you as well. So it's like Vitellius on the Northern Frontier in AD 69. That is exactly right. Being told by his troops, you've got to become emperor of a will. Basically, you're doomed. That is the parallel, of course, that had occurred to me, Tom.
否则，我们也只好把你除掉了。所以这就有点像公元69年北方边境的维特里乌斯（Vitellius）。完全正确。被他的军队告知：你必须成为皇帝，否则没完。基本上，你死定了。这正是我想到的那个类比，汤姆。
The coup begins. It was postponed by a day. It was originally meant to be on the 10th of September. It actually begins on the 11th. At dawn, the Navy capture the port of Valparaiso, a place where Allende had been as a young man, where he'd helped found the Socialist Party and so on. Immediately, the prefect of the province tells Allende what has happened. Allende goes to the presidential palace, La Moneda, in the center of Santiago with his
政变开始了。它被推迟了一天。它原本定于9月10日举行。它实际上在11日开始。黎明时分，海军攻占了港口城市瓦尔帕莱索（Valparaiso），那是阿连德年轻时曾呆过的地方，他在那里帮助创立了社会主义党等等。该省的省长立刻将发生的事情告知了阿连德。阿连德带着他的
bodyguards and with his key ministers. And they're trying to communicate with military leaders. And actually, it's very important to them that they communicate with Pinochet because he's the commander of the army. They can't get through. The telephones are cut off. Communications are down. There's news coming in from Chile that different places are being seized by military units,
保镖和关键部长们前往圣地亚哥市中心的总统府——拉莫内达宫（La Moneda）。他们试图与军方领导人沟通。实际上，对他们来说，与皮诺切特沟通至关重要，因为他是陆军司令。他们无法接通。电话被切断了。通信中断了。智利各地不断传出消息称，不同地点被军事单位占领，
all looking very bad. And Allende, at that point, he really wants to get in touch with Pinochet. And he actually says to his aides, I wonder what they've done with poor old Pinochet. Oh no, that's awful. It doesn't occur to him that Pinochet would have joined the plotters. Very quickly, it is obvious that the coup leaders are going to win. So by about 8.30 in the morning, they declare that they have Chile under control and they are officially deposing Allende because there's a national emergency and all this kind of thing.
情况看起来非常糟糕。而阿连德在那时真的很想联系上皮诺切特。他甚至对他的助手说：“我不知道他们把可怜的老皮诺切特怎么样了。”哦不，这太可怕了。他根本没想过皮诺切特会加入阴谋集团。很快，政变领导人将要获胜已成定局。因此，大约在早上8点30分，他们宣布智利已在他们的控制之下，并正式罢免阿连德，因为存在国家紧急状态以及诸如此类的情况。
And by about 9 o'clock, so two hours after the news has come in from Valparaiso, they are in total control with the exception of a small part of the capital with the presidential palace at its core, where Allende is holed up with his loyalists. Now, the army say, if you do not resign, if you do not surrender, we will attack the presidential palace. We will bomb it. We will hammer it with everything we have. We're not messing around here. Some people in Allende's entourage say to him, escape, get out, run, flee. Maybe, who knows, flee to Cuba, do something.
到了大约9点钟，也就是从瓦尔帕莱索传来消息两个小时后，他们已经完全控制了局面，除了首都的一小部分核心区域——也就是总统府，阿连德正与他的忠诚追随者固守在那里。现在，军方表示，如果你不辞职，如果你不投降，我们将进攻总统府。我们将轰炸它。我们将用我们拥有的一切猛轰它。我们可不是在开玩笑。阿连德随行人员中的一些人对他说：“逃吧，离开这里，跑吧，逃命去吧。也许，谁知道呢，逃到古巴去，做点什么。”
Allende says, no, I'm the democratically elected president. I will stand by the constitution. I am not fleeing anywhere. The military themselves contact the presidential palace and they say, we will fly you and your family out of the country. Now, again, Allende says, no way. But here is the first sign of Pinochet, the real Pinochet, the ruthlessness. Because we now know from amateur recordings that people intercepted the military's own communications and recorded them. There's audio tape of Pinochet talking to
阿连德说：“不，我是民主选举产生的总统。我将坚守宪法。我哪里也不会逃。”军方亲自联系了总统府，他们说：“我们将用飞机把你和你的家人送出国外。”然而，阿连德再次表示：绝无可能。但这里出现了皮诺切特的第一个迹象，真正的皮诺切特，那种冷酷无情。因为我们现在从业余录音中得知，有人截获了军方自己的通信并将其录了下来。有皮诺切特交谈的录音带
his troops and he's laughing. And he says to them, he says to his aides, that plane will never land, meaning Allende's plane if he accepts the offer. And he also says, if you kill the bitch, you eliminate the litter. So the ruthlessness, the very man he was having a meeting with two days earlier, Tom, he's already talking about killing him, about breaking the deal and killing him. Anyway, Iando doesn't take the deal. He reveals at this point something that nobody had previously suspected, which is this extraordinary cold-blooded ruthlessness. He says, if we're going to do this coup, do it properly, kill our enemies. They're calling for helicopter gunships. They're calling
他的部队，他在笑。他对他们说，他对他的助手说，那架飞机永远不会降落，意思是如果阿连德接受这个提议，他的飞机就落不下去。他还说，如果你杀了这个婊子，你就消除了祸根。所以这种残酷，汤姆，就在两天前他还和这个人开会，他现在已经在谈论杀了他，谈论撕毁协议并杀了他。不管怎样，阿连德没有接受这个协议。他在此时展现出了某种以前没有人怀疑过的东西，那就是这种极其冷血的残酷。他说，既然我们要搞这场政变，就要做得彻底，杀死我们的敌人。他们在呼叫武装直升机。他们在呼叫
for aircraft to strike the presidential palace. It takes a while to bring them up to our end. It's got a few more hours. And it's during those few hours that he gives this extraordinary radio speech. So that's the speech with which I began the first episode. Yes. Actually, very Yes. Actually very moving. Incredibly moving. And the thing is that, again, I didn't actually know what happened to him in the coup, but this, again, drawing on the classical parallels, this is very Roman behavior. This is kind of Cato defying an over-ambitious general, destroying the constitution, risking martyrdom. It is exactly. he says to the he
战机轰炸总统府。把它们调到我们这边花了一些时间。还要再过几个小时。正是在这几个小时里，他发表了这篇非凡的电台演讲。这就是我开始第一集的那篇演讲。是的。其实非常是的。其实非常感人。关键是，再次强调，我其实并不知道他在政变中遭遇了什么，但这一点，再次借鉴古典历史的平行对照，这是非常罗马式的行为。这有点像加托（Cato）蔑视一个野心勃勃的将军，摧毁宪法，甘冒殉道的风险。完全是这样。他对人们
says you know to the people must defend themselves but they must not sacrifice themselves and then he says that bit that you read that you began with other i have faith in chilean's destiny other men will overcome this dark and bitter moment when treason seeks to prevail go forward knowing that sooner rather than later the great avenues will open again and free men will walk through them to construct a better society. I mean, you can see why a generation of kind of lefty people in Britain found this so moving that there's a little bit of resentment and recrimination there, but not much. And actually, it's this dream of, it's like something from Les Miserables or something. Well, it's Latin this is this is roman behavior at its very best yeah it's noblest no actually even in the audio that speech is it's terrible crackly audio but
他说，你知道的，对人们说，人民必须保护自己，但他们绝不能自我牺牲。然后他说，你读过的那段、你一开始引用的那段话：“我对智利的命运充满信心，其他人将会克服这个黑暗而痛苦的时刻，当叛国企图占上风时。前行吧，要知道迟早有一天，宽广的大道将会重新敞开，自由的人们将穿过它们，去建设一个更好的社会。”我的意思是，你可以理解为什么英国的一代左翼人士会觉得这如此感人，其中带有一点怨恨和指责，但不多。事实上，这就是那种梦想，就像《悲惨世界》或类似作品中的情节。好吧，这是拉丁语，这绝对是极其典型的罗马式行为，是的，这是最高尚的——其实，甚至在音频中，那篇演讲，音频的杂音非常可怕，但
you can hear hints of the kind of gunfire in the background and things as we approach sort of two o'clock in the afternoon fighter jets are striking at the presidential palace there's tear gas everywhere the smoke everywhere so what happens to all Allende? So he and some of his aides are trying to get out. So he is trying to get out, is he? Well, wait for it. He says to them, let's all try to get out and surrender. There's about 30 people. They start to go out. There's a guy called Dr. Patricio Aguijon, I think it is. And he's one of Allende's doctors. And he tells the story that the fires in the palace, they start to go out. Allende says, I'll take up the rear. And then as they start to go out, Allende slips away.
你能听到背景中枪声的隐约声音以及各种杂音。随着时间接近下午两点左右，战斗机正在轰炸总统府，到处都是催泪瓦斯，到处都是烟雾。那么阿连德后来怎么样了？所以他和他的几位助手正试图逃出去。所以他正试图逃出去，是吗？好吧，接着往下看。他对他们说，让我们一起试着逃出去并投降。大约有30人。他们开始往外走。有一个人叫帕特里西奥·阿吉翁（Patricio Aguijon）医生，我想是这个名字。他是阿连德的医生之一。他讲述了这样一个故事：宫殿里的火灾开始熄灭。阿连德说，我来断后。然后当他们开始撤离时，阿连德溜走了。
And this guy, the doctor, goes back to see what's happened to Allende. And he sees him in Independence Hall in the palace with the AK-47 that fidel castro had given him and he puts it in his mouth uh i think it is and basically blows his own head off the two bullets now that's not the story that was told that was often told after and his death because fidel castro just a couple of weeks after this, told a big crowd in Havana that Allende had died in battle, fight firing at Pinochet's troops. And of course, there are lots of people- He sees that as a more heroic- More heroic death.
这个人，也就是那个医生，回去看看到底发生了什么。他在宫殿的大独立厅（Independence Hall）里看到了他，手里拿着菲德尔·卡斯特罗送给他的AK-47步枪，他把它放进嘴里——我想是这样的——基本上把自己的脑袋轰掉了。两颗子弹——现在，这并不是后来经常被讲述的故事，在他死后，因为就在这之后仅仅几周，菲德尔·卡斯特罗在哈瓦那向一大群人宣称，阿连德是在战斗中牺牲的，是在向皮诺切特的军队开火时阵亡的。当然，有很多人——他认为这是一种更英勇的——更英勇的死法。
There are lots of people who wanted to believe that. And so it became a very popular idea though. I think the whole, the echoes of cato killing himself rather than submit to caesar i think that it's just as heroic if not more i mean it it absolutely casts him as a martyr and that's the role that that he then plays isn't that brutus and cassius yes they kill themselves as well that idea of suicide rather than submit to an autocrat i mean it is a very ancient tradition yeah and i think it's generally agreed that's what happened. There was an autopsy by Spanish pathologists or whatever they are, forensic scientists in 2011. You can Google it. And they said, yes, this is pretty much no doubt
有很多人愿意相信这一点。因此这变成了一个非常受欢迎的观点。不过，我认为加托宁死不向凯撒屈服的呼声和回响，我认为这同样英勇，甚至更甚——我的意思是，这绝对把他塑造成了一个殉道者，而这正是他后来扮演的角色，难道不是吗？布鲁图斯和卡西乌斯也是如此，对吧？他们也自杀了。这种与其向独裁者屈服不如自杀的想法，我的意思是，这是一个非常古老的传统，是的。而且我认为人们普遍认为事情就是这样的。2011年，西班牙病理学家或某种法医专家进行过尸检。你可以在谷歌上查到。他们说，是的，毫无疑问，
that Allende took his own life. So we should just talk about how the coup is wrapped up. By the afternoon of September the 11th, it's pretty much all done and dusted. Allende's ministers are generally either killed immediately or they're flown to concentration camps, particularly a concentration camp in Chilean Patagonia or an island. I think what surprises people in America is that the Chilean military is so bloodthirsty. I don't think they saw that coming because there's no hint of it. So that's including the CIA? I mean, maybe they did, but I don't think... The CIA prepare a paper for Henry Kissinger at the end of October where they basically say, we haven't actually been able to add up,
阿连德是自杀身亡的。所以我们应该谈谈政变是如何收场的。到9月11日下午，一切基本都已经尘埃落定。阿连德的部长们通常要么被当场杀死，要么被空运到集中营，特别是智利巴塔哥尼亚的一个集中营或某个岛屿。我认为让美国人感到惊讶的是，智利军方竟然如此嗜血。我认为他们没有预料到这一点，因为此前没有任何征兆。所以这其中也包括中情局吗？我是说，也许他们料到了，但我认为……中情局在10月底为亨利·基辛格准备了一份报告，他们在报告中基本上表示，我们实际上一直无法统计出伤亡的正确数字，
get a correct tally of the casualties because there have been so many. We think that the military have probably killed about 1,500 people. And would that include the ministers? What happens to the ministers in the concentration camp? So some of them are killed, some of them aren't. Some of them are tortured and then let out. They've probably rounded up at first about 13,000 to 14,000 people. Now, very famously, a lot of those people are housed in the Chilean National Stadium. I mean, this is a detail that lots of people will remember from this story, the football stadium. At one point, there were 7,000 people in there. They used the field itself, the football field, to hold the men. The women are held in the many of them are, they're thrown into the river or their bodies are dumped in the ocean or they're just dumped at night in the streets. And there were some very, very well-known examples of people who were killed. So the best known Chilean one,
因为死伤实在太多了。我们认为军方可能已经杀害了大约1500人。这其中包含部长们吗？集中营里的部长们怎么样了？所以其中一些人被杀了，一些人没有。一些人遭受了酷刑然后被释放。他们最初可能围捕了大约13,000到14,000人。现在，非常出名的是，许多这样的人被关押在智利国家体育场。我的意思是，这是一个许多人都会从这个故事中记住的细节，那个足球体育场。一度有7,000人被关在那里。他们利用球场本身，也就是足球场来关押男性。女性则被关在许多人被扔进河里，或者他们的尸体被抛进大海，或者他们只是在夜间被扔在街头。有一些非常非常著名的被杀害的例子。所以最著名的智利人，
at least outside Chile, is a guy called Victor Jara, who was a poet and a sort of folk singer and stuff. He had written Allende's election song in 1970. He had performed at a ceremony to honor Pablo Neruda when Neruda won the Nobel Prize for Literature. Victor Jaro is seen as the kind of great balladeer of the Chilean left, and he is killed in a smaller stadium, the Estadio Chile, five days after the coup. For our American listeners, they will undoubtedly know this
至少在智利境外，是一个叫维克托·哈拉（Victor Jara）的人，他是一位诗人和某种民谣歌手之类的人物。他在1970年写了阿连德的竞选歌曲。他在巴勃罗·聂鲁达获得诺贝尔文学奖时的致敬仪式上进行过表演。维克托·哈拉被视为智利左翼伟大的民谣歌手，他在政变发生五天后在一个较小的体育场——智利体育场（Estadio Chile）被杀害。对于我们的美国听众来说，他们无疑会知道这个
story. A lot of them, it's immortalized in the film Missing with Jack Lemmon and Sissy Spacek. There was a guy called Charlie Horman. He was a Harvard graduate who had gone to Santiago to try and become a writer and a filmmaker. He'd been really into the Chilean regime. By hideous mischance, he was in the seaside town of Viña del Mar when the coup broke out. And he's got into conversation in a bar or something like that, or in a hotel with some Americans. And the Americans said, oh, we work for the US Navy. We're just down here doing a job. And it's done. We're going to go home now. And he's like, oh, what's the job? And the mood turns very icy. He goes back to Santiago. He is eventually rounded
故事。他们中的很多人，这个故事在杰克·莱蒙和茜茜·斯派塞克主演的电影《失踪》（Missing）中得到了永生。有一个人叫查理·霍曼（Charlie Horman）。他是哈佛大学毕业生，曾前往圣地亚哥试图成为一名作家和电影制作人。他一直对智利政权非常感兴趣。由于一次可怕的阴差阳错，政变爆发时，他正身处海滨小镇比尼亚德尔马。他在一家酒吧或类似的地方，或者在一家酒店里与一些美国人交谈。美国人说，哦，我们为美国海军工作。我们只是到这里来执行一个任务。任务完成了。我们现在要回家了。他说，哦，什么任务？气氛顿时变得非常冰冷。他回到了圣地亚哥。他最终被围捕。
up. He is taken away. He is taken to the national stadium and he is tortured and killed. So I'm surprised about that because I would have thought that... I mean, doesn't that risk relations between the new Chilean regime and the United States if they're busy torturing and executing American citizens? Well, it's not the only one. There was also a guy called Frank Terugi who was working for a pro-ANDE newspaper. He was tortured with electrodes and killed in the national stadium too. They knew each other, actually. The Americans know almost immediately that Charlie Holman has been killed. Whether it was a mistake, we don't know. Whether actually he knew too much.
他被带走了。他被带到国家体育场，在那里遭受严刑拷打并被杀害。所以我对此感到惊讶，因为我原以为……我的意思是，如果他们忙着折磨和处决美国公民，难道这不会危及新智利政权与美国之间的关系吗？嗯，他不是唯一的受害者。还有一个叫弗兰克·特鲁吉（Frank Terugi）的人，他当时在一家亲阿连德的报社工作。他也同样在国家体育场遭受电极酷刑并被杀害。其实他们俩认识。美国人几乎立刻就知道查理·霍曼被杀了。这究竟是个错误，我们不得而知。还是说其实他知道得太多了。
I mean, that's the implication of the film missing. Because he'd spoken to these sailors. Because he'd spoken to these Americans. So this conversation plays a huge part in missing. The idea that he's basically stumbled into something and has to be eliminated. The extraordinary thing is that his father, Ed, and his wife, Joyce, launched this great hunt for him. And Ed, played by Jack Lemmon in the film, comes to Santiago, and he goes to the embassy. He talks to people from the embassy and the CIA. They lie to him.
我的意思是，这就是电影《失踪》所暗示的。因为他和这些水兵交谈过。因为他和这些美国人交谈过。所以这段对话在《失踪》中扮演了极其重要的角色。那种他基本上无意中卷入了某些事情而必须被消灭的想法。非同寻常的是，他的父亲埃德（Ed）和妻子乔伊斯（Joyce）对他展开了大规模的搜寻。电影中由杰克·莱蒙饰演的埃德来到了圣地亚哥，他去了大使馆。他与大使馆和中情局的人交谈。他们对他说谎。
They say, we've heard that he's escaped. He's been smuggled to safety, knowing that he's dead. And then when they finally admit he's dead, he's been murdered, all this, the State Department, and this is an unbelievable detail, they sent Ed Harmon a telegram telling him that he needed to pay $900 to have the body shipped back home to the United States. So a pretty grim story, and not the only grim story. A month after the coup, Pinochet sets in motion something called the caravan of death that's not good is it so one of his um associates a guy called general Ariano Stark he goes off with a load of other officers and they tour the country going to the provinces
他们说，我们听说他已经逃走了。他被偷运到了安全地带——明知他已经死了。然后当他们最终承认他已经死了、他被谋杀了、所有这些之后，国务院——这是一个令人难以置信的细节——给埃德·霍曼发了一封电报，告诉他需要支付900美元才能将遗体运回美国。这是一个相当残酷的故事，而且并非唯一的残酷故事。政变发生一个月后，皮诺切特启动了一项名为“死亡大篷车”（caravan of death）的行动——这可不是什么好事，对吧？所以他的一个同伙，一个名叫阿里亚诺·斯塔克（Ariano Stark）的将军，带着一大批其他军官出发了，他们巡视全国，前往各省，
and in each province they identify people and they tell them to hand themselves in they're trade unionists poets lefty people all of that sort of tell them to hand themselves in. They're trade unionists, poets, lefty people, all of that sort of stuff. These people hand themselves in often. They're put into cells and they're taken away and then they're tortured, bayoneted and shot. And this anticipates what's going to happen with something called DINA, which is the Directorate of National Intelligence, which becomes this kind of great institution for kind of arresting people, torturing them, disappearing them, all of this kind of thing. So that's one element of the post-coup regime. The other element that nobody could possibly have anticipated before the 11th of September
在每个省份，他们辨认出一些人，并告诉这些人主动自首。他们是工会成员、诗人、左翼人士，诸如此类。告诉他们主动自首。这些人往往真的自首了。他们被关进牢房，然后被带走，接着遭受酷刑、刺死和枪杀。这预示了后来被称为“迪纳”（DINA，即国家情报局）的机构将要做的事情，这个机构后来成为了一个庞大的体制，专门负责逮捕人、折磨人、让他们失踪，诸如此类的事情。所以这是政变后政权的一个组成部分。另一个在1973年9月11日之前绝对没有人能预料到的因素是，
1973 was that Pinochet himself would prove as ambitious and ruthless as he did. So the junta, the military regime, is meant to be a rotating regime. The army will have a go, the air force will have a go, the navy will have a go. And Pinochet goes first because he's the oldest, the army is the most senior. He'll do it for six months or whatever, then hand it over. And he doesn't. He basically uses his power straight away to browbeat the other services into accepting him as the supreme chief of the nation. That's what he calls himself. And he sets up a personality cult. So people start to say, Pinochet has been chosen by God. He has the special approval of the Virgin Mary to destroy
皮诺切特本人证明了自己具有极强的野心和冷酷无情。因此，军政府，也就是军事政权，本来应该是一个轮流执政的政权。陆军轮流执政，空军轮流执政，海军轮流执政。而皮诺切特最先上台，因为他是年纪最大的，陆军资历最高。他干六个月左右，然后交权。但他没有。他基本上立即利用手中的权力，蛮横地迫使其他军种接受他作为国家最高领袖。这就是他自称的头衔。他建立了个人崇拜。因此人们开始说，皮诺切特是上帝挑选的。他得到了圣母玛利亚的特别批准，来消灭
communism. And the coup was necessary. He is the savior of the nation. Mrs. Thatcher explicitly picks up on this in that speech at the beginning that you quoted, Tom. He saved us from communism and he is the great Chilean national hero. And so by 1974, he has supreme power in a way that nobody had possibly predicted. Does he have sunglasses, a bigger uniform, bigger hat? There's a very famous photograph of him sitting. you know, not long after he's been named as Supreme Chief. He's sitting there with all his officers and he is wearing the classic dark glasses. And he mentioned his hat. As the top man, Captain General, that's the title that has not been used in Chile since the days of Bernardo O'Higgins, the great liberation hero. As Captain General, he has a hat that is slightly bigger than everybody else's hat. So what the Americans didn't pick up on in those intelligence reports was the vanity that would reveal itself once he became supreme leader. And of course, his regime, Tom,
共产主义。这场政变是必要的。他是国家的救星。撒切尔夫人在你刚才引用的那篇演讲中明确指出了这一点，汤姆。他把我们从共产主义手中拯救出来，他是伟大的智利民族英雄。因此，到1974年，他拥有了以一种无人曾预料的方式呈现的最高权力。他戴着太阳镜，穿着更大的制服，戴着更大的帽子吗？有一张非常著名的照片，他坐在那里——你知道的，就在他被任命为最高领袖不久后。他坐在那里，周围都是他的军官，他戴着标志性的深色墨镜。你刚才提到了他的帽子。作为最高长官，大将（Captain General），这是自智利伟大的解放英雄贝尔纳多·奥伊金斯（ Bernardo O'Higgins）时代以来智利再未有人使用过的头衔。作为大将，他戴着一顶比其他所有人的帽子都要稍微大一点的帽子。所以美国人在那些情报报告中没有察觉到的是，一旦他成为最高领袖，他那虚荣的本性就会暴露无遗。当然，他的政权，汤姆，
I mean, it's not just controversial because of the coup. It's controversial because under his leadership, probably 3,000 to 4,000 people were killed and about maybe 30,000, 20,000 to 30,000 tortured. So that understood. I mean, he really does sound as bad as the myth makes him. And yet, Mrs. Thatcher, she's Baroness Thatcher, standing up in the House of Lords, saying he's tremendous. I mean, I don't want to say there's another side to a guy who's toppled a democratically elected government and murdered and tortured left, right, and centre and given himself a bigger hat. But for Mrs. Thatcher, there are two things he does, right? So he supports Britain in the Falklands, and So she feels grateful gratitude for that. But he is also a kind of, she sees him as a kind of fellow Thatcherite, someone who institutes an economic revolution that she sees him as a kind of fellow traveler like that.
我的意思是，它之所以饱受争议，不仅仅是因为那场政变。它之所以充满争议，是因为在他的领导下，可能有3,000到4,000人被杀害，大约20,000到30,000人遭受酷刑。这一点大家都清楚。我的意思是，他听起来确实和传闻中的一样糟糕。然而，撒切尔夫人，也就是撒切尔男爵夫人，却站立在上议院说他太棒了。我的意思是，我并不是想为这样一个推翻民主选举政府、大肆谋杀和折磨左翼右翼及各方人士、还给自己戴一顶更大帽子的家伙辩护说他还有另一面。但对撒切尔夫人来说，他做了两件正确的事：第一，他在马岛战争中支持英国，所以她对此心怀感激。但同时，他也算是一种——她将他视为某种同道中人，一个开启了经济革命的人，她把他看作是志同道合的同路人。
A little bit, yeah. So to what extent is there any justification for the case that she was making for him, do you think? Oh, that's a very difficult, I mean, that's ultimately a political decision that you, the listener, make. Whether you think that... There'll be some listeners, probably not a majority, but there'll be some listeners who say, listen, Allende was making a terrible mess of things. This was a Cold War. Chile was sliding towards Cuban-style socialism. If we had Chilean listeners, Tom, I don't really think we'd do.
有点像，是的。那么，她为他辩护的理由在多大程度上是有道理的呢，你觉得？哦，这是一个非常棘手的问题，我的意思是，这最终是一个政治决定，需要由你——听众来做出判断。无论你认为……会有一些听众，可能不是大多数，但会有一些听众会说，听着，阿连德把事情搞得一团糟。这是一场冷战。智利正在滑向古巴式的社会主义。如果我们有智利听众，汤姆，我觉得我们其实没有。
But if we did, there would certainly be some of them who would say that. And they would say, Pinochet saved the country from this slide into the abyss of Marxism. Despite the violence with which he did it, the brutality with which he did it, despite the rupturing of the Constitution. They would say, listen, the Constitution, neither here nor there, this was an emergency. And they would say of the violence, that was better than the violence that would have come if a revolutionary Marxist regime had seized power. And that's what they would want to, presumably, well, I'm guessing, I mean, that's not necessarily what I think. I'm kind of guessing what they would say.
但如果我们有，肯定会有一些人会这么说。他们会说，皮诺切特把国家从滑向马克思主义深渊的边缘拯救了回来。尽管他采取了暴力手段，尽管他采取了残酷手段，尽管他破坏了宪法。他们会说，听着，宪法算不了什么，这是非常时期。他们还会说，关于暴力，那总比一个革命性的马克思主义政权夺权后可能带来的暴力要好。而这正是他们想要——据我推测，好吧，我只是在猜想，我的意思不一定代表我个人的看法。我只是在猜测他们会说些什么。
I think for Mrs. Thatcher, for Ronald Reagan, for all the myriad actually Western governments that supported Pinochet or smiled upon his regime, they were operating in a Cold War context where actually they quite often supported authoritarian regimes. I mean, the Chilean regime is not unique in South America. Argentina, Brazil, or Uruguay, they all have very close links with the Americans. But what I hadn't appreciated was the depth of the democratic traditions within Chile. I suppose there's a slight measure, again, going back to the Roman echoes of Sulla choosing to lay down his power. With Pinochet?
我认为对于撒切尔夫人、罗纳德·里根以及所有无数实际上支持皮诺切特或对其政权报以微笑的西方政府而言，他们是在冷战的背景下运作的，在那个背景下，他们其实经常支持威权政权。我的意思是，智利政权在南美洲并不是独一无二的。阿根廷、巴西或乌拉圭，它们都与美国人有着非常紧密的联系。但我之前没有意识到的是智利国内民主传统有多深厚。我想这其中也有一定程度的相似之处，再次回到古罗马关于苏拉（Sulla）选择交出权力的回响。是指皮诺切特吗？
With Pinochet. No, I think that's...... Mrs. Thatcher is wrong about this, I think, when she gives that... So she's got that wrong? There was a referendum, absolutely right, at the end of the 1980s on whether he should continue, and he lost. He didn't really want to call the referendum. He was pressured into calling the referendum by younger officers, by people in politics. Okay. Because it does seem a bit, I was thinking it does seem a bit out of character, this bloodless yet ruthless brute. And he insists on retaining kind of titles and a kind of, you know, it's like a kind of professor emeritus.
是指皮诺切特吗？不，我认为这是……撒切尔夫人在这一点上弄错了，我认为，当她发表这种……所以她搞错了？确实举行过全民公投，千真万确，在上世纪80年代末，关于他是否应该继续执政，结果他输了。他其实并不想举行公投。他是被年轻军官和政治界人士施压才不得不举行公投的。好吧。因为这确实看起来有点——我当时在想，这与他那个冷血却残暴的恶霸形象有点不符。而且他坚持保留各种头衔以及某种——你知道的，就像某种名誉教授。
Yeah. The big hat and all that sort of stuff. Absolutely. So the idea that he said this kind of ultimately kindly man lays down his power and retires to grow cabbages is not quite correct. I mean, that's not the case at all. So, I mean, I do think it's probably too, you don't understand what happened with the coup unless you understand the Cold War context, the immense fear on both sides of something worse. And there will be people in Chile right to this day. There are
是的。那顶大帽子以及诸如此类的事情。绝对是的。所以那种认为这个最终心地善良的人主动交出权力、隐退去种卷心菜的说法并不完全正确。我的意思是，事实根本不是这样的。所以，我的意思是，我确实认为，如果不理解冷战背景、双方对更糟情况的巨大恐惧，你就无法真正理解政变中发生的事情。直到今天，在智利仍然有人——
lots of people in Chile to this day who say, oh, Pinochet saved us from Marxism. Well, so this guy who's ahead in the polls that we've got in this episode talking about. Yeah, cast. Exactly. There are lots of people who would... So I think it's perhaps too... It's a little bit like that thing about thinking about the Americans as the omnipotent puppet masters. It's easy to think, oh, everybody in Chile was actually a folk music aficionado who loved nothing more than free milk. But actually, there are loads of people who are horrified by Allendean.
直到今天，智利仍然有很多人说：“哦，皮诺切特把我们从马克思主义手中拯救了出来。”好吧，就像我们在这一集里讨论的民调领先的这个人一样。是的，卡斯特。正是如此。有很多人会……所以我觉得这或许有点过于……这有点像把美国人想象成全能的木偶操纵者的那种想法。人们很容易认为，哦，智利每个人其实都是民谣音乐爱好者，除了免费牛奶什么都不爱。但实际上，有大量的人对阿连德感到惊恐。
Of course. I mean, that's the fascination of history and how it can shade into politics. I think, yes, exactly. That you're, to me, not to a lot of historians on Twitter, I think it's fair to say, but to me, one of the central aspects of being a scholar of history is trying to put aside your own political prejudices rather than just blindly indulging them. On Pinochet, I think I'll tell you one thing that occurred to me, Tom, while I was preparing this podcast, which is you talked in the first episode about Costa Rica, comparing Costa Rica.
当然。我的意思是，这就是历史的魅力所在，以及它如何能演变成政治。我认为，是的，完全正确。对你而言——虽然对推特上的很多历史学家来说可能不是这样，我觉得可以这么说——但对我而言，作为一名历史学者，核心职责之一就是尽量抛开自己的政治偏见，而不是盲目地放纵它们。关于皮诺切特，我想告诉大家一件事，汤姆，我在准备这期播客时想到的，那就是你在第一集里谈到了哥斯达黎加，拿哥斯达黎加做对比。
Individuals do have choices. So in Costa Rica, we talked about the Civil War of the 1940s and this guy, Don Pepe, who won power and he abolished the military. And then he actually turned out to be a tremendous fellow. He was about two feet tall, wasn't he? And he was foiling hijacks and just doing all kinds of good things. Pinochet didn't have to electrocute all those people. He'd taken power. He didn't have to keep killing them. He didn't have to have the caravan of death. He didn't have to do all those things.
个人确实有选择的权力。所以在哥斯达黎加，我们讨论了20世纪40年代的内战，以及这个叫东佩佩（Don Pepe）的人，他赢得了权力，然后他废除了军队。后来事实证明他真的是个了不起的家伙。他身高只有两英尺左右，对吧？他阻止了劫机事件，还做了各种各样的好事。皮诺切特本不必电刑折磨所有人。他已经夺取了权力。他本不必继续杀人。他本不必搞什么“死亡大篷车”。他本不必做所有这些事情。
He had a choice. And actually, you can have military coups and authoritarian regimes, some that are better than others. The regime of General Pinochet himself was very corrupt. He amassed an enormous fortune and his family, billions and billions of dollars. The continuation of the machinery of repression, I would argue, was totally unnecessary. And so I think an attempt to sort of rehabilitate him and to say, I think that it found us on those facts. I suppose, I mean, there's an element of Macbeth, isn't there? I am in blood, stepped in so far that should I wait no more, returning were as tedious as goer, that once you start removing your predecessor and murdering
他有选择。而且事实上，你可以有军事政变和威权政权，有些政权比另一些要好。皮诺切特将军本人的政权非常腐败。他聚敛了巨额财富，他的家族积累了数十亿甚至数百亿美元的财富。我认为，继续维持镇压机器是完全不必要的。因此，我认为任何试图为他平反、说他情有可原的企图，都是站不住脚的。我想，我的意思是，这其中有一种麦克白式的悲剧色彩，对吧？我踏血已深，若要回头，其难如登天，一旦你开始铲除前任并谋杀
people, the murdering just has to carry on because otherwise you're worried that you're going to be toppled. I think there's a huge element to that. I think the extraordinary thing is that he'd lived so long, to late middle age, and he hadn't killed anybody or electrocuted anybody. And then when he has the chance, he turns out to be so savage. I think that's the remarkable thing. You know, he's not Stalin. He hasn't been a gangster as a boy or hadn't been involved in revolutionary organizations. He's just been a boring, institutionalized kind of officer.
人们，谋杀就必须继续下去，否则你会担心自己会被推翻。我认为这里面有很大一部分因素。非同寻常的是，他活了那么久，直到中老年都没有杀过任何人，也没有电击过任何人。然后当他有机会时，他竟然变得如此残暴。我认为这才是最引人注目的地方。你知道，他不是斯大林。他年轻时不是黑帮分子，也没有参与过革命组织。他只是一个无聊的、体制化的军官。
And then he has this chance and he seizes it. But maybe that makes him more chilling. I mean, more kind of frightening. The idea that a dull functionary can suddenly start throwing people out of airplanes and things. Of course. He reminds me a bit of General Franco, another very boring man who turns out to be just very bloodthirsty. And again, a man about whom people have very, very strong and polarized opinions. Because there would be some people who say,
然后他得到了这个机会，并抓住了它。但也许这让他更令人不寒而栗。我的意思是，更令人恐惧。一个沉闷的官僚竟然可以突然开始把人从飞机上扔下去等等。当然。他让我想起了弗兰科将军，另一个非常无聊的男人，结果证明他极其嗜血。同样，这是一个让人们有着非常强烈且两极分化观点的人。因为总会有人说，
oh, Dominic beating up on General Franco, shocking wokery, General Franco actually saved Spain. I don't think there are that many, though, now, who would... General Franco. Maybe people at The Spectator? Because Franco is seen as a fascist, and to be seen as a fascist puts you beyond the pale. But Pinochet, perhaps, is seen as a, I don't know, a free marketeer. I'm not saying that it's true. I have no way of knowing. Pinochet is much closer to Franco than he is to Margaret Thatcher, I would say. I mean, there's a point actually in the early 1980s, Tom, just on the Margaret Thatcher thing. I mean, it's unusual that we do a podcast where I haven't spoken up for Mrs. Thatcher in some way, because I do think sometimes she gets a bit of an unfair press. But
哦，多米尼克在痛斥弗兰科将军，真是令人震惊的“觉醒”行径，弗兰科将军实际上拯救了西班牙。不过，现在持这种观点的人大概没那么多了吧……弗兰科将军。也许《旁观者》（The Spectator）杂志的人会这么想？因为弗兰科被视为法西斯分子，而被视为法西斯分子就会让你彻底名誉扫地。但皮诺切特，或许被视为一个——我不知道，一个自由市场主义者。我并不是说这是真的。我无从知晓。但我得说，皮诺切特更接近弗兰科，而不是玛格丽特·撒切尔。我的意思是，在20世纪80年代初，汤姆，就撒切尔夫人的事而言，其实有一个节点。我的意思是，我们做一期播客却没有以某种方式为撒切尔夫人辩护，这很不寻常，因为我确实认为有时她得到的舆论评价并不太公平。但
just on this, there's a point where she has a meeting, actually, not with a Chilean minister, but with an Argentine minister. And they say, oh, our economic experiment works really well. And when people complain about unemployment and stuff, we just electrocute them and it's fine. And she says, I don't approve of these methods at all. And she actually writes to Friedrich Hayek, the economist who's one of the founding fathers of this revolution, says, these are not methods that we would want to copy in Britain. So there you go. Okay. Well, on that pro-Thatcherite note, I think we should say hasta luego. Thank you very much for listening. Thank you for a brilliant account of this seismic episode in Latin American history. In fact, it's a seismic, globally,
就在这件事上，有一个节点，她举行了一次会晤——实际上不是与智利大臣，而是与阿根廷大臣。他们说：“哦，我们的经济实验运作得非常好。当人们抱怨失业之类的事情时，我们就直接对他们施以电刑，一切就都解决了。”而她说：“我完全不赞同这些方法。”她实际上还写信给弗里德里希·哈耶克（Friedrich Hayek），这位这场革命的奠基人之一的经济学家，信中说：“这些绝不是我们想在英国效仿的方法。”所以你看。好吧。带着这种亲撒切尔的调调，我想我们该说再见了（hasta luego）。非常感谢大家的收听。感谢你对拉丁美洲历史上这起震撼性事件的精彩阐述。事实上，这是一场震撼全球的、
it's a seismic event. It still continues to reverberate to this day. So thank you very much for listening. Adios. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works.
震撼性的事件。它的余波直到今天仍在回荡。非常感谢大家的收听。再见（Adios）。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐至上》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。
We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、额外单集以及提前购买现场活动门票的特权，请访问 therestisentertaiement.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。